oh it's gonna get interesting today dude
go home hey what's going on YouTube now
I've heard a lot of stupid [ __ ] in my
life
haha but this one probably definitely
takes the cake now I'm pretty sure you
guys heard of this guy named Josh a
friggin assisted it's this time I don't
know depressive man but he started this
movement now what is this movement you
asked is the hashtag Merry Christmas
Starbucks movement now this was brought
to my kitchen by a friend of mine which
at first I didn't really think was real
now you have to ask yourself what is
this whole hashtag thing about well this
guy Josh decided to put out this video
about Starbucks not going ahead and
putting Merry Christmas or saying Merry
Christmas or putting festive designs on
their cups anymore the uproar is about
Starbucks changing their red cup into
yes a regular red cup no God please no
no no no first of all I just what the
[ __ ] I have never heard of a problem so
much in my life that that's not a
problem you want to talk about
complaining about [ __ ] nothing this
would be it you're mad because the
Starbucks cup just turned plain red and
took off it's Christmas festivities here
let me uh who the [ __ ] cares the
Starbucks cups in the first place didn't
have anything Christian about it it was
like it was like little Christmas balls
sleds and [ __ ] leaves what the [ __ ]
that had to do with Jesus how do you
take removing Christmas ornaments on a
cup is saying a company hates Jesus and
that Christ is losing number one
Starbucks is not a religious institution
you [ __ ] Kevin James fat fred durst
looking [ __ ]
oh no don't insulting there's nothing to
do with what she said shut the [ __ ] I
say what the [ __ ] I want that's right
you look like the dude on King of Queens
why would you wake up one day decided
you know what I'm gonna be a sitcom
Karen and let's go ahead and talk a
little bit more about your [ __ ] so I
did a little bit of research on this guy
and he does a lot of these like
religious fanatic videos number one you
[ __ ] crook I believe you did a
kickstart to what get a red camera right
what happened to that red camera by the
way this [ __ ] with that $20,000
that he raised bought two 5d Mark
what the [ __ ] did the rest of the money
go that always has to be some idiot that
takes a religion and bashes it
constantly because you think that you
can exploit it for your own profit I
will say this now if you are a follower
of Christ and you're gonna go ahead and
put hashtag Merry Christmas Starbucks
because you think that you're doing
something positive for the Christian
religion Wow chop off your feet you
don't think there are bigger problems in
this world called hashtag stop world
hunger you [ __ ]
hashtag improve our education system
hashtag end poverty
hashtag feed me I'm hungry there's
nothing and then on top of that you're
gonna tell people why don't you go into
Starbucks today and buy a coffee and
pipe Merry Christmas I didn't say it's
your name [ __ ] you're going to
support the [ __ ] business that you
hate so much by buying a cup of coffee
what the [ __ ] tell them your name is
Merry Christmas oh that's right you're
leading a war no look you know you know
what the most amazing part about this is
it's not the fact that somebody could
make a big deal out of nothing
is that there are other people that will
follow this man and make a big deal out
of nothing and then on top of that at
the end of the [ __ ] video he goes I'm
gonna wear my Jesus Christ shirts
because Starbucks hates Jesus so much
and by the way says you hate the Second
Amendment I have a [ __ ] God it's
frightening to me more or less of the
fact that there are people that follow
this man and agree with him why do you
people care about the color of the cup
and by the way just on an aesthetic
point the new cups look way better oh
that's right you're awaiting a war now
look it wouldn't be nice if you did
something positive for Christianity sir
I mean I know that you think that you're
doing something right but goddamn I
never wanted to punch somebody in the
face so much my life I mean let's leave
this as an open discussion by the way
how do you feel about the Starbucks red
cup hey do you feel like it's a loss for
your religion then people like deferring
away from Christ or - who the [ __ ] cares
and I would understand wants to get a
little more if Starbucks was a religious
institution and their Starbucks cups
originally had like Jesus's face on like
if Jesus was on the front of the cup and
on the side in a pody bubble it said my
child come to salvation and have a cold
brew cranberry bliss bar No cranberry
bless bar I want to say if I ever meet
this guy I want to take my samurai sword
and then chop off like his kneecaps
slowly and then attach
to his cheeks but you know it's on the
video muffin I got gun I'm crazy [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]